des préoccupations légitimes voilà
comment sergueï lavrov nomme les
demandes russe dans le conflit à l'est
de l'ukraine à l'issue de leur rencontre
hier à genève anthony blinken et sergueï
lavrov ont accordé chacun de leur côté
une conférence de presse malgré les
tensions latentes le dialogue ne semble
pas rompu les précisions de notre
correspondant à moscou antoine perreault
à la suite de la rencontre entre anthony
blinken et sergey lavrov le ministère
russe des affaires étrangères a publié
un communiqué dans la soirée de vendredi
dans lequel il est promis aux
occidentaux de graves conséquences s'il
continue d'ignorer les préoccupations
sécuritaires de la russie anthony
blinken a été clairement informé que le
fait de continuer à ignorer les
préoccupations légitimes de la
fédération de russie liées
principalement à l'exploitation
militaire en cours par les états unis et
leurs alliés de l'otan du territoire de
l'ukraine dans le contexte d'un
déploiement à grande échelle de forces
et moyens de l'alliance près de nos
frontières on aura les conséquences les
plus graves une façon pour moscou de
mettre la pression sur washington
concernant les attentes russe en terme
d'engagement concret de la part des
partenaires occidentaux à savoir entre
autres que l'ukraine ne rejoigne pas
l'otan la partie russe attend désormais
une réponse écrite de la partie
américaine dans les prochains jours et
de cette réponse dépendra la réaction de
la russie pour le moment il n'y a pas de
réponse formelle écrit de la part des
états unis et de l'otan à nos
propositions si cette réponse est
décevante alors des décisions politiques
très graves devront être prises comme le
président a averti les adversaires de
l'autre côté y compris publiquement
cette nouvelle rencontre au plus haut
niveau à genève n'aura donc pas permis
de faire baisser la pression même si le
dialogue diplomatique reste intense et
plus régulier que jamais dans le cadre
de cette crise en ukraine prochaine
étape désormais la réponse américaine
par écrit washington s'y est engagé aux
propositions russes concernant sa
sécurité